in this age of artificial intelligence
many companies are focused on creating
highly humanoid robots that can work
closely with actual humans in the
hospitality and customer service sectors
so it is evident that these reports are
designed to look more like humans and
act like one as well
they have skin they have eyes but they
are not made with flesh and bones the
latest iterations can talk like us walk
like us and express a wide range of
emotions
some of them can hold a conversation for
a long time and others can even remember
the last interaction
you might recognize them as robots at
present still they would be almost
indistinguishable from real human beings
in the future but for now let us see the
top 5 humanoid robots in the world in
current times let's get started
at number 5 we have nadine an empathetic
robot which returns greetings makes eye
contact and remembers all the
conversations that have been had with it
she is a human-like robot with
personality moods and emotions this
report was created to look like dappal
ganga of her creator professor nadia
hallman this glowing skin and flowing
green thread humanoid robot can
recognize you from previous visits make
eye contact shake your hand continue
chatting based on previous meetings and
so on
nadyan was developed by kokoro japan
with a software platform developed at
nan yang technological university in
singapore she has 3d depth cameras a
microphone and a webcam to gather visual
and audio inputs
then there are various perception layers
that process these inputs to recognize
different faces gestures emotions and
behavior so she can analyze and respond
accordingly
she currently works as a receptionist at
aia singapore an insurance company and
the next in the line we have geminoid dk
it is the latest iteration of german art
series of ultra realistic robots
this humanoid report is the result of a
collaboration between private japanese
firm and osaka university which was
supervised by hiroshi ishiguro the
director of the university's intelligent
robotics laboratory gemini dk was
designed after danish professor henrikh
sharfe of albert university in denmark
not only his overall appearance was
inspired but his behaviors and even the
way he shrugs were also fed into the
reward
this spot is so very realistic as people
tend to be mistaken for the person which
was designed to look alike
the main purpose of this creation is to
make the humanoid look completely like a
human
at number three we have junko chichira
another astonishingly realistic looking
android robot created by toshiba works
full-time in a tourist information
center in tokyo she was the successor of
ikea jachira who worked as a
receptionist in a department store in
japan
jungkook
is a part of a much larger effort by
japan to prepare for the 2020 tokyo
olympics not only will she work in
tourism and service industries she will
also jump into healthcare for older
people
hitoshi takuda the chief specialist of
toshiba's research and development
center informed that the humanoid would
be combined with any kind of language
processing system
right now she is capable of
communicating in english japanese
chinese and sign languages
next on our list we have grgi this
chinese humanoid robot puts on a charm
in shanghai gigia is admired by people
all around the world for her most
realistic and enduring appearance
this astounding beauty can hold a normal
conversation with a person with a
microbial facial expression
she does that with the help of speech
generation algorithms and facial
recognition technologies
though her speech patterns are still not
smooth giga makes it up by looking
remarkably human-like her entire action
is controlled by cloud technology
geogea has such realistic expressions as
special emphasis was given to her eyes
so that she can catch different gestures
emotions behavior and so on team leader
shen zhaoping said proudly that with a
little more effort geogear can see a
bright future of her kind as we all
expected the number one on our list is
sophia sofia debuted in the year 2016
she was one of a kind and her
interaction with people was the most
unlikely thing we can ever see in a
machine she was designed by a hong kong
waste company hanson robotics and was
created to look like audrey hepburn a
famous hollywood actress because the
goal of the creators was to fit her as
an old age companion in nursing homes or
a crowd manager in evens
the sole purpose of this creation was to
make the robot gain social skills and
communicate with human beings
sophia was embedded with neural networks
and artificial intelligence to recognize
human faces and understand their
gestures and emotions
she can also interact with different
people and also respond appropriately
humans getting citizenship is normal but
in 2017 sophia made history by becoming
the first android to be granted legal
citizenship in saudi arabia in greek
sofia means wisdom and that is what she
is
in the near future she would obtain more
wisdom and become more empathetic to
help humankind and other beings ai and
humans can live and work together in
friendship and make the world a better
place so imagine having a sofia or
geogra besides you when you're all alone
and in need of a companion or when
you're sick and in need of proper
nursing
when you can get knowledge through a
metallic human instead of banging your
heads with laptops works tablets etc
life would be more convenient and stress
free
these ultra realistic robots look
exactly like humans although their
behavior still needs more improvement to
resemble like a human completely this
may change in the future with increasing
advances in artificial
intelligence hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simply learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here